you
[Music]
one two three four five six seven eight
nine and zero with just these ten
symbols we can write any rational number
imaginable but why these particular
symbols why ten of them and why do we
arrange them the way we do numbers have
been a fact of life throughout recorded
history early humans likely counted
animals in a flock or members in a tribe
using body parts or tally marks but as
the complexity of life increased along
with the number of things to count these
methods were no longer sufficient so as
they developed different civilizations
came up with ways of recording higher
numbers many of these systems like Greek
Hebrew and Egyptian numerals were just
extensions of tally marks with new
symbols added to represent larger
magnitudes of value each symbol was
repeated as many times as necessary and
all were added together Roman numerals
added another twist if a numeral
appeared before one with a higher value
it would be subtracted rather than added
but even with this innovation it was
still a cumbersome method for writing
large numbers the way to a more useful
and elegant system lay in something
called positional notation previous
number systems needed to draw many
symbols repeatedly and invent a new
symbol for each larger magnitude but a
positional system could reuse the same
symbols assigning them different values
based on their position in the sequence
several civilizations developed
positional notation independently
including the Babylonians the ancient
Chinese and the Aztecs by the eighth
century Indian mathematicians had
perfected such a system and over the
next several centuries Arab merchants
scholars and conquerors began to spread
it into Europe this was a decimal or
base 10 system which could represent any
number using only 10 unique glyphs the
positions of these symbols indicate
different powers of 10 starting on the
right and increasing as we move left for
example the number 316 reads as 6 times
10 to the 0 with power plus 1 times 10
to the first power plus 3 times 10 to
the second power a key breakthrough of
this system which was also independently
developed by the Mayans was the number 0
older positional notation systems that
lacked this symbol would leave a blank
in its place making it hard to
distinguish between 63 and 603 or 12 and
120 the understanding of zero as both a
value and a placeholder made for
reliable and consistent notation of
course it's possible to use any 10
symbols to represent the numerals 0
through 9 for a long time the glyphs
varied regionally most scholars agree
that our current digits evolved from
those used in the North African Maghreb
region of the Arab Empire and by the
15th century what we now know as the
hindu-arabic numeral system had replaced
Roman numerals in everyday life to
become the most commonly used number
system in the world so why did the
hindu-arabic system along with so many
others use base 10 the most likely
answer is the simplest that also
explains why the Aztecs used a base 20
or vajay simal system but other bases
are possible too Babylonian numerals
were sexagesimal or base 60 and many
people think that a base 12 or
duodecimal system would be a good idea
like 6012 is a highly composite number
that can be divided by two three four
and six making it much better for
representing common fractions in fact
both systems appear in our everyday
lives from how we measure degrees and
time to common measurements like a dozen
or a grouse and of course the base two
or binary system is used in all of our
digital devices though programmers also
use base eight and base 16 for more
compact notation so the next time you
use a large number think of the massive
quantity captured in just these few
symbols and see if you can come up with
a different way to represent it
[Music]
you